l'année dernière la commission
parlementaire sur les pesticides s'était
penché sur l'utilisation trop grandiront
certain que l'on fait de ses produits
dans nos champs au mois d'octobre le
ministère de l'agriculture du québec a
présenté sa réponse à cette commission
avec son plan d'agriculture durable le
plan de l'agriculture durable déposé par
le gouvernement du québec s'attaque aux
pesticides pour améliorer le bilan
environnemental du secteur agricole
mais québec fiction aussi des objectifs
pour les dix prochaines années afin de
protéger les sols l'eau de même que la
biodiversité
si ce plan reçoit un bon accueil
certains groupes à revanche trouve qu'il
manque d'ambition qu'en est il au juste
d'abord une nouveauté le ministère de
l'agriculture récompensera les
agriculteurs qui adoptent des pratiques
plus soucieuse de l'environnement
on veut encourager ceux qui vont au delà
des exigences réglementaires
ceux qui par exemple élargissent des
bandes riveraines ou pratique la lutte
biologique aux ravageurs au chapitre des
pesticides
le gouvernement veut que les
agriculteurs réduisent l'utilisation de
ces produits
ils achètent à eux seuls près des trois
quarts de tous les pesticides vendus au
québec
l'objectif est de réduire les ventes de
ses produits de 500 1000 kg d'ici 2030
c'est le chiffre marque les esprits
certains groupes estime que c'est trop
peu à preuve ce graphique
ils montrent une baisse constante des
achats de pesticides depuis 2014 à ce
rythme québec atteindrait sa cible sans
difficulté et ce bien avant 2030
le ministère de l'agriculture métier que
son objectif reste ambitieux car au
cours des prochaines années
les agriculteurs devront composer avec
des mauvaises herbes résistantes aux
herbicides les maladies au chant
pourrait aussi être plus fréquentes en
raison du réchauffement climatique qui
allonge les saisons de croissance
les groupes environnementaux rappelle
que le ministère de l'agriculture
s'étaient dotées en 2011 deux cibles sur
les pesticides et que certaines d'entre
elles ne sont toujours pas atteinte avec
son plan québec veut aussi améliorer la
santé des sols pour passer à
l'agriculture durable
pour y parvenir on mise sur les
couvertures végétales
il s'agit de laisser aux chants des
résidus de cultures ou mieux encore de
recouvrir les sols avec des cultures
comme les céréales d'automne
tout juste avant l'hiver actuellement
60% des ter sont recouvertes en hiver
par des résidus ou des cultures on veut
accroître ce chiffre à 75%
cette mesure permettrait d'atteindre un
autre objectif important celui
d'augmenter la matière organique de nos
sols chaque année les sols se vide un
peu plus de leur carbone une tendance
qui inquiète
l'autre grand objectif est ici les
fertilisants étendue aux champs l'azoté
le phosphore sont essentiels aux plantes
mais ils deviennent de puissants
polluants
quand ils sont en surplus
d'ici 2030 québec veut réduire de 15%
les apports de ces deux fertilisants une
baisse d'azov diminuerait les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre produits auchan
quant au phosphore il est directement
liée à la santé des cours d'eau trop de
phosphore nourrit les algues et leur
prolifération asphyxie la vie des plans
d'eau en ciblant les pesticides l'eau et
le sol
on touche aux véritables enjeux
environnementaux en agriculture
il faudra attendre que québec précise
les moyens pour atteindre ses objectifs
avant de qualifier ce plan de virage
vers une agriculture durable
en
[Musique]